Hello.
Should be live here.
How's it going? Happy Saturday.
It's been a long week. Productive. A lot
of work done.
Long week though.
I intended to be up here and uh doing
the stuff by 9:00 a.m. It is
11:18.
A little bit late, but uh we do have the
rest of the day blocked out for material
science work.
Doing something kind of cool today. I
have no idea if it'll work. Um, I had a
long discussion with a material
scientist and I think it should work.
But generally, we're going to try to
bind puffer lib to a material science
simulation package to see if we can cast
the problem of discovering a material
with this as an interactive optimization
task and get puffer lib to do that.
I'll go over the details of that as we
get into it a little bit more, but for
now, hey, that guy, how's it going? Uh,
let me see can do.
So,
get a few things set up.
I want to do this locally or remote.
Probably locally maybe.
Yeah, probably we just do it locally,
right? Maybe we don't have any issues
with SSH
rendering.
All I need to do is I looked a little
bit about at this package ahead of time
just so that we wouldn't be completely
from scratch.
So,
lamps.
And uh yeah, it's just a CMake.
I remember I kind of did a trial run of
this.
I didn't get as far as actually figuring
out how to use the CAPI, but I did make
sure there is one. Got to get my daily
or else stood fix out here every day
making it happen. Hey, I've been gone
this week because I've been doing work
in person. And I've been an SF.
Oh, wait. I'm dumb. Hang on. I didn't Am
I not in the container?
right. I forgot that it's the dumb
Windows thing.
Oh, right. Okay. I don't have the Yeah,
that's fine. Never mind. We're good
then.
Yeah, we're fine. This should hopefully
work
What did I do? Did I actually just ran
cm make
to help with super flat structures?
Yeah, I don't actually have any material
science background reference.
I'm kind of just guessing that I'm going
to be able to figure it out.
I did discuss this uh in depth with a
material scientist though and we think
that the idea makes sense. I don't know
any of the details. Um I do know that I
probably
going to be in a better place to figure
out the engineering and especially
hooking it up though than most would be.
API headers.
Okay.
So, we can try this
and then we'll go to Puffer and we'll
try to like get some basic demo.
No one has tried. Oh, I didn't even
realize that was you. Welcome, Yaxine. I
didn't see the name on it.
How's the uh robotics going?
I wish I could have been around like
more to help this past week, but it's
literally
I think I was doing stuff earlier in the
week as well, but like Wednesday,
Thursday, Friday, it was pretty much day
started at 6:30 a.m. and then I didn't
get back until after dark at the least.
basically have a client using uh puffer
liib widely and I'm trying to get them
into a spot where like they can be much
more productive with the research and
how they're using it.
Someone just hit 3k stars. Did we hit 3k
or is it rounded to 3k? Cuz before it
was rounded to 3k.
I'll post when we actually hit 3k.
Oh, holy.
That's freaking awesome.
Material for invisibility cloaks.
Honestly, like as far as sci-fi tech
goes,
that's like not even my top
my top thing at all.
It's cool, but not my top thing.
Uh,
I've got to get myself into the actual
engineering mindset again because
meetings all week.
We have 2,000 in the Discord yet or not
quite.
The 2,000 in the Discord.
I'm just going to assume it is
now doing reward design. Oh, wait. Hang
on. Crashing into walls.
You mean the Sim derails crashing into
walls?
3001. Thank you. Oh, welcome. Yeah, I
replied to your DM, I believe. Come
build some stuff with us.
Do you just not have a sensor? Cuz like
obviously
if it can't see where the walls are,
right?
You could do that even with just one
depth sensor though, right?
Well, something's not hooked up right.
It should be it should be very easy to
learn like to not crash into walls.
So, I would identify whether it's a
problem in the sim or it's a sim to real
or it's like
yeah, something screw for sure.
Like I would understand if okay it's
harder to hover because there are
physics assumptions that aren't baked
in. Not crashing into the wall should be
pretty See?
There we go. Back to real work.
Lamps built.
and this gives us probably headers on
global path
maybe.
Where's the API?
The API. We want this, right?
Okay, they do have
I just run this
Uh,
it's already on the path. I probably
have to link, don't I?
Oh, actually, this does show up.
Oh, hang on. Why? That's being included
correctly. Then why
not working?
There like extra compile flags you need.
Oh, hey Ken Vert. And hey, uh, welcome
as well. And what are you making? I am
trying to get uh figure out how this
material science package works and get
it bound to puffer liib
build test.
I just want to get like a standalone
file that I can build in the simplest
way possible. I figure I'm missing some
args.
They have
probably in CMake, right?
I It's annoying that I have to like go
through and find
flags.
Oh no, this is a gigantic file, man.
Do they not just have um
GCC flags somewhere
or how to do this
flags? Okay,
I don't see any debt like any extra link
stuff.
Uh
we compile this thing.
Add library.
Alge.
Okay. So, it links a whole bunch of
stuff.
And it looks to me like
uh that's only set up with make or with
cmake at the moment.
Am I understanding this right? It
shouldn't I be able to just build
build an archive where it just has
everything in it already?
Yeah. The problem is I'm trying to
I just want to link in the static
archive, don't I?
Yeah, I shouldn't have to add to one
giant.
I guess it depends how it's set up,
right? if if it compiles statically or
if it's like linking in everything.
Oh, wait. There's there is a thing here,
is there?
It's got to be G++
because there's a C interface
to a C++ package, I believe.
Hey bet.
Freaking C make, man.
Go to the traditional make tab.
Did I Did I miss that? Oh,
why are we making things?
I'm just trying to figure out how to get
lamps to work. Bat material science
package.
I'm trying to figure out how to get like
just a simple GCC. I guess G++ working
would do it, right?
Is it clang++? I thought clang just base
all worked for um D or C++. I thought
the package just had both in it.
Scientist it is in the kitchen. I
Oh, where is it in the
I where Currently this is brand new.
We're just trying to figure out how to
get the package to even build.
We have some reasonable ideas on what to
do, but um
I don't know there was there was
information here library of C++ and
executable
For some reason, I thought clang just by
default had um both compilers.
I shouldn't have to rebuild lamps. I
have it built.
Yeah, I should just be able to link it,
right?
Wait for creating a shared library. All
the libraries it depend on to be
compatibility
the case for all libraries included with
lamps.
Okay.
Why is this not
like something is just not clicking?
I'm just not understanding something
about how this package works.
I don't think I should be including
source library.h, right?
Yeah, it's probably that I need I
probably need to like add the link flag
and just include library.h or whatever,
don't I?
Yeah, it's it's probably something like
something like this, right? And then you
add like L L lamps or something.
Hey, did you
seeing you after months and you're fit
right now? Honestly, I think I'm less
fit at the moment. I've gotten a bunch
of injuries that make it pretty hard to
uh
do all the exercise I want to do. I'm
still in decent shape though.
Doing a 10k tomorrow with some hills.
then you can compile with GCC and L
lamps
what we would want.
I think this is right. Then we can
compile with just GCC
because I'm just use I'm just writing C
and we're just linking this API. I think
this is how this works.
working directory.
Wait, what?
Shouldn't need to alter the headers.
Well, lamps is the name of the package,
right?
Hey, Spencer. I'm just getting started
on it. We're figuring out how to get the
package set up and to use the C API.
It's probably going to be the most
difficult part honestly is just figuring
out the basics of the package.
Shouldn't be that hard to get it bound
to puffer from there and run Perf tests
and such.
Good job on that article.
You're doing really well with the uh the
promo.
Had so many meetings in the last few
days that at the end of one of them
yesterday, I just like got up and said,
"All right, out of brain cells for the
time being.
I don't know. Let's see. Did we pass for
Tural? I don't think we did yet.
It's going to be very close.
Oh yeah, we did.
Yeah, guys, we passed um we passed the
metabacked
reinforcement learning library. Isn't
that crazy?
And actually, isn't this older than
Puffer? Wait, hang on.
Yeah. Okay, this library is literally
older than Puffer Lib. It's metabacked
and we've just passed it.
Well, if I The thing is, if I do post
this, then possibly a bunch of people
will go star this.
But uh yeah,
this is kind of crazy.
You haven't passed Torch Tune or Torch
Titan.
I don't think those are actual like
Aren't those L? Yeah. No, LLM libraries
don't count, dude. Yeah, obviously the
like the libraries that are for the
space that has tens of billions of
dollars of investment we haven't passed.
That's not apples to apples. This is way
closer comparison.
Like the things to consider on this
things this base are like SP3 and such,
right? Those are the bigger ones which
have like way longer time advantage.
Yeah, we've passed torch. That's crazy.
3k stars.
Having fun with this
accomplishment for the day.
Vincent left Meta. Yeah, I know.
Well, but this is the thing, right? It's
like you put out a thing that's backed
by the big company name, you don't
actually invest in it. And like also the
design of it is way ridiculously high
level. It really the design doesn't make
any sense for where RL is a field.
Like the design of the library, it's
like
it would only make sense pretty much if
RL were as mature as uh supervised
learning is, right? Where you can just
grab different components and make
something that works roughly the way
that you'd expect.
And frankly, I don't even think that I
will be the one to make a library for
that uh when RL gets to that point.
After all, it would be kind of sad if uh
you know, Puffer actually gets RL to be
the stable insane field and then
somebody else just like, "Okay, cool.
Now we can build the dumb library
because everything is solved." Not
Puffer. Maybe I will.
Even for more mature stuff like yeah you
can have more sort of reusable
components I suppose but torch RL is
still too high level for my liking even
if that were the case the best possible
situation.
try this then.
Okay, so there's no lamps library.h.
Double check it exists. All right.
Should have installed it globally,
right? That's kind of what we're
expecting.
I mean, that's also possible. If
somebody wants to build a front end on
top of Puffer, that's also kind of fine
by me, right? But it's kind of difficult
to do that with the way that Puffer is
at the moment. It's really not designed
for that. I mean that's something I
would be more open to doing though
longer term, right? Is like
I guess it would be more so like the
better analogy is something like Caris I
guess um where if people want that type
of an interface like I'm not going to be
the one to build that but sure you can
build that. I would probably do like the
lower level interface
but I would actually make it so that you
could build a higher level interface on
top.
My tea guys started the live.
I slept in a little bit. All right. It
was a long week. A lot of work.
Do I even need to build this thing from
source?
going to modify or extend
amps
Maybe we can just literally get the uh
the package.
Do you have lamps? Sure. Yeah, that's I
don't know. It's I was supposed to build
it there. I'm pretty sure
I worked with Isaac Jim and uh more
recently a little bit with Manny Skill.
The heck
cannot just install this
App install.
That should give me access to the uh
like that will actually get me the
header files as well, right? For the
API. It won't just give me like the CLI
options.
I just need the simplest way possible to
use the uh the C API of this material
science simulation package
plus material science. What are you
cooking good sir? Well, pretty much the
initial idea is can we can we just
pretend all the atoms are agents and
have them steer themselves into a
configuration that produces a certain
property that we want like the initial
idea.
I have discussed this with an actual
material scientist who says it's not
completely crackpot.
No.
Come on. No, I'm not implementing the
alchemi paper.
Is that RL?
I didn't think that there was any RL
with material science. I thought it was
like se like generative model or
sequence modeling.
What's the full name?
Oh, no. That's totally different. No,
not that one.
Yeah, that's that's completely
different.
soft matter material RL. That's cool.
Well, I mean, we're going to be like
whatever RL is out there with material
science, we should just be able to kind
of crush
like we have orders of magnitude more PF
alpha chip.
Alpha chip is actually, I think, harder
than this, ironically.
I think um I think material science is
actually going to be much easier to
solve with RL than ship placement.
I could be wrong,
but at the very least the way that like
it's a very different formulation.
Control active pneumatics and other
soft.
Okay. See, it sounds like you actually
have a background in this, unless you're
just googling things. So, uh, we this is
kind of the point of streaming this
stuff, right? We need people who
actually have some knowledge, domain
specific knowledge. I have zero, right?
I know how to build things. I'm a
reasonably competent engineer. I know
about a lot about reinforcement
learning. I've built very very high
performance reinforcement learning. What
can we do?
So, here I I will tell you the initial
idea, right? So the initial idea of the
thing that we want to do here
uh is to okay so in material science
right when you use simulations in
research a lot of it is you kind of set
up the simulation the way you think it
should be run it you spend a bunch of
compute you see what happens if it's not
what you want you try something else so
instead what we want to do is specify
the outcome of what you want to see
happen like I want a material that has
this type of heat dissipation for
instance and I know These are the atoms
that we're going to use. This is what
it's going to be made out of. I don't
know how they like the arrangement, what
how they should be configured. Okay,
we're going to have all the atoms steer
themselves into the configuration that
maximizes uh the specific property we're
interested in. We're going to do that by
RLing, literally just driving the atoms
around. And we're going to see uh if we
can get that property then you'll just
be able to look at the configuration of
the atoms and say ah okay I need to know
how to I need to figure out how to
produce a material that has this crystal
structure or whatever and then it will
have this heat property I'm interested
in
genetic algorithm search that is
incredibly inefficient.
Yeah, genetic algs are incredibly
inefficient.
Learning force fields with RL.
I don't know if we're learning force
fields with RL.
You kind of don't have to.
You're allowed to sort of break the laws
of physics a little bit with um how you
move the atoms around. As long as the
final structure has integrity, right? As
long as like the final structure is
stable under the physics sim, it kind of
doesn't matter how you get there.
I don't understand why this pack is set
up this way. Will the sort of said
material be done step by step? Yes.
harder than so you would do it by like
literally you're assuming that you have
something that you can run to check the
hardness of a material. So like the
atoms steer a little bit, you check the
hardness. The atoms steer a little bit,
you check the hardness and then that's
the reward. The difference in hardness
is the reward. For instance, in that
example
structures are predictor physical
properties self assembly. There's a lot
of effort to reverse engineer how
individual units must interact in this
structure. Yes. So this is absolutely
punting on how do you actually get the
material into this structure. Uh but at
the very least you can know that some
like a structure exists based off of
this right.
inverse design of soft materials. Oh
okay cool. So yeah it's kind of this
except that evolution is horribly
horribly inefficient.
Yeah. Okay. This is the word though,
inverse design.
Okay. But like the difference here,
right, is like genetic algorithms suck
and don't actually work. And do we have
some of the most ludicrously optimized
deep uh deep RL in existence,
right? So, we could potentially do
something like this. Let me actually
download this and save it for All
right, I'll just keep the tab on the
other monitor.
Matter is too complicated to put into
them.
Well, that's not true of all matter,
right? Like simulation is leveraged
extensively in material science and in a
whole bunch of other fields, right?
boltman type configuration and training
loss in memory.
Wait, what?
I highly doubt you need to do anything
specific to the actual RL because it's
material science
that you, it's been my experience, you
really don't need to do anything fancy.
it. You just use our stuff. You get fast
sim. You get an appropriate reward
function and it should work. The RL is
very good now. OMD opers lowle API
alternative lamps.
What? Okay. This is not lamps not
working well. This is just me not having
it installed correctly, right?
Ah, okay. Cool. So, it actually includes
this, but now it doesn't have NPI.
Not ignored. Okay. Well, it's actually
doing something.
Open. No. MPI.
science dedicated puffer go hard. I
mean, this is my ultimate goal with
puffer, right? I care about science and
like making ridiculously cool sci-fi
tech. That is kind of my goal for
everything ultimately. It's just a lot
of other applications are more obvious
and more immediate, right?
I think neuromorphic computing would be
I have no idea what that is.
Yeah, I've never heard that word.
Holy, we've got at least 22 people plus
everyone on X. Welcome a fun stream
doing this all day. Ideally, not dealing
with compilation all day. We want to
actually do some real material science.
Wait. Neuromorphic computers based on
big. Yeah. What the heck is
neuromorphic?
I have no idea what this is or how it
works.
Parallel. How is this not just a GPU?
somehow more energy efficient.
Is this This is still silicon, isn't it?
All right.
If somebody who actually knows what this
is wants to explain it, I'd be happy to
chat.
Real science discovery used LMS. You
know, we're not doing Here's the thing
with LLMs for this type of stuff. It's
kind of right? Cuz like this
is you have very simulationheavy fields
and LLMs are just like human intuition.
You're not going to intuitit your way
into like guessing the outcome of sims
or whatever, right? You have to actually
run the sim.
The RL is the thing that you would use
to be interacting in real time or faster
way faster than real time actually uh
with the sim in order to edit components
of it online in ways that are very
unintuitive are not captured by human
intuition but are like superhuman at
optimizing
draws inspiration from how energy
efficient. No idea how that works. Um,
that would be very useful though because
we are going to have uh if it act if
that actually works cuz we're we're
going to have an energy problem pretty
soon with all of the uh the chips we
have we're bringing online, right?
I mean, realistically, like you can kind
of just scale solar for quite a while,
but it will be very expensive
Well, it's not like LLMs are dumb, but
it's like people are overusing them.
They don't make any sense in this
context.
Okay, they have a whole bunch of uh of
examples apparently.
Can we use RL to get faster physics sims
to model my
So, it's not necessarily that you get
faster physics sims. It's that you can
the way we're doing stuff is you can
write faster physics sims that are less
accurate and have still get useful
results because RL
also target the system once the most
important features of certain pro
possibly I'm going to have to figure out
how to set this up in a way that
actually makes sense for the RL right
like the devil's in the details
quantum Um,
look at see what this is.
We have source files anywhere.
Uh, yeah, none of these are source
files.
We just have input files, right?
This is like some domain specific
language.
And they have all these things. But like
where is
Yeah, this is not example code. These
are just this is like the DSL for
calling the package.
What?
What is happening here?
Why void value
not ignore
ought to be
I finalize? But we don't even get to
that, right? It's
of quantum equals infinite quantum
processing power. Quantum equals nothing
works yet.
I got this off of their example.
And these are literally just like
example. There's no API here.
They have library.h included here.
I mean, is this
are you supposed to do this? Does make
any sense?
Yeah. No, right? Because
why would it make any
I guess that they're like targeting
their local build or something, right?
This is just like if you compile this
from
like the source,
but then I don't understand how
Yeah, there's also like a dev and it
doesn't
weird.
Trying to build something that mimics a
neuron.
Okay. So I I guess the thing I don't
understand with that, John, is like
you can kind of do this in like you can
emulate this just on a a traditional CPU
and basically you have to you actually
have to have like a model that produces
something useful,
right? So I mean possibly what you're
doing is different hardware for
different like more bioinspired deep
learning models, but those have to work
first, right? What are you working on
today? I'm trying to get material
science uh material science package
simulator hooked up and I'm just having
some difficulty getting everything set
up correctly. For some reason, this is
just like I I can't get the install
working yet.
I guess I can just guess that maybe
I don't think you should need this for
the sample script.
It's also possible, I suppose. Let me
just
Yeah, we have the same error.
How to go beyond theory of our own to
actually projects. You read my guide
on X.
So, uh, if you just do if you go to my
tab,
this is a literal step-by-step guide on
exactly how to get into reinforcement
learning and start productively
contributing to research.
like actually like do this, do this,
read this, read this, do this, read
this. Congratulations. Now you're a
researcher.
I've tried to make it as straightforward
as possible because I get this question
constantly.
This is exactly what I've had other
people do in Puffer that have like that
are now actually contributing to our
research.
Defense Department's interested. What?
Yeah. I don't know how these things go
together though because like
You can't come up with a new theory of
computing, right, without
actually being able to compute useful
things.
Not using the Python API. Screw that.
We're going to get the C API working.
Make it
not quite what I was saying with that.
Nobody gotten this. I'm confused. Like I
expect that almost nobody uses the C
API, but
current value is void, but you're trying
to assign it to a nonvoid variable.
What?
Their test script just wrong.
int
arg candle
equals.
So did this change and like nobody
updated it or something?
test or something
test
e library
test main.h page.
I don't know why they have the test in
C++
if they have SC library.
Google mock what?
Oh, okay.
Test library MPI test library commands
open.
See, this is not a a CAPI test, right?
This is Isn't this the
No. Okay. This is just a pound andh
Oh, yeah. Thanks for the reminder, B.
Yes, please do start the library. It
does help me out a lot.
Join the Discord if you want to get
involved with dev.
Okay. Well, this is just bizarre to me
because they say they have a C API, but
like the tests are in C++ as well.
Something is screwy.
Test of the C library interface. They
just wrote the test in C++ or something.
All right.
Test library open. I think this is the
right file.
They have library and then they have
lamps.h included.
Is it do I need like a different
As soon as I get anything working on
this, it's going to be quite quick cuz
like as soon as I have something to
iterate on,
I can get like a couple basic sims
running. I should be able to get a
visualizer up hopefully and then like
the binding process to RL is not that
hard
as soon as I get the problem set up.
fun.
Lots of views on this.
You actually I can't see how many people
are currently watching on X. It only
tells me total views, but uh hi to
everyone watching over there.
If anybody knows how this package works,
please be my guest. And uh tell me why I
can't get the example to run.
Functions only declared Okay, hang on.
Function is only declared when the code
using lamps library.hinc include file is
compiled with d lslubmp npi
contains a defined statement before
including library.h
related to this note.
Wait, where where is that note?
Did you see it from the LLM or is it
like actually in the docs or something?
I didn't see that note.
Like it shouldn't even be using the MPI
at all.
Yeah, Spencer's post has done very well.
It's good for him. He's like been doing
great work.
Can't endorse him enough.
C++ specific header.
Okay. Lambs.h is a C++ specific header.
Okay. So, we don't want this.
You don't want to include lamps.h.
Want library.h. page.
We don't want this.
Oh, hang on. Functions like lamps return
a void star handle directly
called version from apt
older signature
requires passing
handle.
Ah, and this is an old version of
Abuntu.
The third argument to set it.
Okay. So, it's the the docs are for the
new version. Okay. So, you should just
build
we should just build the latest thing
and then figure out how
how to get that to run, right?
And then possibly on like 24 or whatever
when we go to install it on our servers,
we won't have to do from source. Um, but
for this thing, I do have to do from
source.
I mean, when he says doing construction,
he means managing like pretty large
construction operations.
So,
Okay. So, we're here.
We do have to do
Then this should give us user local.
Okay. So, the hope is that this
uh this should get us the new
new version.
DJ J.
Okay. So,
uh, does this now do anything?
undefined reference.
Okay, so we still need
Okay. So now we have this in here,
right?
So now we have library.h
is not that big.
Kind of has all our functions.
So there's lamps MPI finalized. So this
should definitely be here, right? If
we're including this, it should
definitely be
Yes.
Um,
I don't know if this has done anything,
but it actually does run.
So, yay. Right.
Opens prints version runs. Cool. So,
what happened was uh the system package
for Abuntu was outdated and the library
script was targeting the latest version.
So, now we actually should be able to uh
to do something with this. Uh, why did
all the viewers on Twitch just die out
instantly?
Did the Twitch stream crash
or is it botted?
Oh, it's still here.
That's weird.
It's weird cuz YouTube doesn't do that.
The Twitch one's like Yeah, the Twitch
one's probably bots. Okay. Um, this
works. Now we actually get to build
Sims. I'm going to grab a cup of coffee
real quick and we are going to get to do
the real work. Right back. Let me forget
to unmute my mic.
Let's see uh the CAPI examples,
right?
Hitting or deleting lamps. Executing
commands.
There are multiple ways to drive a
simulation.
All encoding have lamps act on a series
of input file commands that are either
read from a file or passed as strings.
That's kind of slow.
I mean, this is the interface that we
have. So, cool.
What sim environment are you building?
Uh, this is a hook into the lamps
material science package for
atomic level simulation.
So, we're just we're trying to hook into
a material science package. Um, set up
some basic simulation
and see how we can uh change some stuff.
It seems like the C API is kind of uh
well no this is kind of okay, isn't it?
It seems like it's very much C++ and the
C API is done after.
It's kind of like it's kind of janky for
C
just mirrors. This kind of almost look
like Python, right? Like they wanted
they do everything strings for some
reason.
just get an atom I suppose, right? Like
actually this is an old enough package
that uh
uh the LM should actually be able to
like at least get me basic setup.
Okay. Okay. So, it's actually it's not
that bad if I think of it as the
commands are well documented and the CPI
kind of just runs the commands.
Kind of crazy that it does everything
through these strings.
Really wouldn't expect that
up the simulation
velocity.
Did it really do everything through
string commands?
Crazy gross.
atom positions can modify be modified
directly via the pointer from extract.
That's what we want.
Okay. Let's see what they gave uh what
this gives me. So, they kept this and
then it added this blob here.
First of all, let's see if this runs.
Okay,
so uh this actually looks good. Position
after manual move.
Okay, so units
I don't know what this does. Dimension
three boundary
atomic style atomic par dummy parasyle
for no interaction
region box block
create box.
Okay. Now load a single atom at a
specific position. Create atoms one
single
setup for running simulations. Time step
and integrator
time step O5
all and V track print the initial
position
0000 1 0
Run a minimal command to in uh minimal
simulation initialize
Move the atom directly. Modify the
positions array. Re-extract the pointer
for safety after commands.
Okay. So you can directly just change
this. That's fine. Position after move.
Hang on.
Initial position. Position after manual
move.
After first run with velocity,
this reextract and print position after
run. Demonstrate running a simulation.
Set the velocity and run. Animal move
based on velocity during the run.
We re extract in after the run moved by
V * DT time steps
05 in
position after first run with velocity.
It doesn't look like it's moved, right?
And then after this. So it's almost
there except it doesn't seem like it's
moved. This code runs but uh the
velocity calcs don't seem to be working
your similar one ideal gas particle.
Yeah. So this is a trivial simulation
John. Pretty much all I want to do uh
initially is can we steer around
can we just steer around an atom? But
like if I can get this to work where you
can set velocities and it behaves as
expected, then what I can do is I can
take this code, I can put it into an RL
simulator, right? And I can hook up the
actions to PE to be the velocity or
whatever and see if we can steer around
the atom.
And if we can do that,
if we can do that,
um, then we're actually like we have a
basic setup for doing RL plus material
science.
Having multiple atoms from an RL
perspective, like that's easy.
Obviously, the simulator is going to get
slower and more complicated. We can do
stuff from here.
granular control like modify velocities
and positions. Yes, that is the goal.
No, no, no. We're not. It's We're going
to actually do like micro
like the more stuff that we give the RL
the better because otherwise these sims
are very slow. So, I want the RL to have
as much control over the SIM as possible
because otherwise it's going to need
tons of data to Okay.
Yeah. So, this didn't do anything,
right?
I think it just gave me the exact same
code back.
Well, I Let's see if I can figure it
out.
You set the green screen to a gym.
Darkness is very irritating.
What? You want me to green screen myself
into my gym? So like even though I'm not
physically at my gym,
what do you mean the darkness is
irritating?
I work closely with soft matter
experimentalists on control problems and
therefore the action space
macro variables. This way they can use
RL to control their experiments.
So John, typically with RL because
here's the thing, your simulations are
slow, right? So uh you want to collect
as much interaction data as possible for
the RL because RL needs a huge amount of
data, right? Like RL really likes your
simulator to be fast. When your
simulator is slow, the best thing you
can do is kind of like try to
parameterize it more heavily. So at
least the RL is getting like pretty
constant feedback on very small changes.
The home gym, go outside, take a picture
of my garage gym, and put myself in
there.
uh not run velocity
run 10?
Am I crazy here? Is this just not
moving?
And so moving it works, but then running
the sim doesn't work.
Does anybody understand what's going on
here?
the NVE. Eat.
error style zero was set without no
co-fair
co-f to fully initialize the pair
interaction
zero computes no okay
hairstyle zero Oh
error pair co-ops are not yet set.
Okay.
Oh wait, am I in the right?
I am in the right right spot.
Now add no co-off avoid needing pair
co-off
wrong here
dimensions atomic file
seems fine isn't it
what is lamps why you're messing with it
what's the end goal uh lamps is a
material simulation package it's used in
material science research
I am messing with it in order to see if
we can use reinforcement learning to aid
in the discovery essentially and testing
of new materials in simulation.
And uh the current goal is to be able to
steer around an atom and hook it up to
puffer. So puffer liib can steer around
an atom in a package. And then from
there I will talk more to the material
scientist I know on like how we should
set up an actually useful sim once we
have benchmarks, make sure it's actually
fast enough to be useful and uh stuff
like this.
manually steer it with what? With RL. It
doesn't have to physically make sense,
right? If I can steer the atoms into a
configuration that produces a heat
dissipation property or like a
structural integrity or whatever that we
want, you can look at the final
configuration and say, "Ah, this is the
material I have to make."
Well, you don't necessarily need atomic
force mic. Like the material scientist
might just look at it and go, "Oh, yeah,
that's a totally standard standard
crystal lattice. I know how to make
that, right?" Or like, I don't quite
know how to make that, but I have some
reasonable ideas. And like, hey, this is
a heck of a lot better than me having to
guess not only how to make the thing,
but like what the structure should even
be.
Oh, this is actually kind of cool that
this thing this is really good that
they've done this. Uh I saw it was
trying to go to the source code to like
look at the details.
Good job to the X team.
But uh unfortunately it kind of just
spits out the same thing as far as I can
tell. Oh no, hang on. It did add a line.
It added a line here. I don't know why
it like just gave me the whole
additional script and just spit out.
Ah,
here we are.
See what this is.
loop time
time steps per second is 39 89,000.
Okay,
Position after manual move.
Second run. Okay, hang on.
Position 505. Perfect.
Perfect. We have it working. Good job.
Good job, Grock. Um, so now
who's ready for a material science sim
plus RL, right?
Uh, the one slightly obnoxious thing is
the one very slightly obnoxious thing is
my editor.
I don't have a super maven.
I would really like my um my
autocomplete to work.
Well, I can handle that just by doing
the dev on the remote server and then
I'll just pull it down. Yeah, let's just
do it that way. It'll be easier.
You're making an item from scratch now
using Well, it's not exactly from
scratch using lamps, right?
I mean, lamps is doing a lot of the
heavy work here, at least for the
initial bit till I understand this more.
We might end up just doing our own
stuff.
This is like a very initial pilot
project, right? Like this is one of many
things I do where if it shows promise
quickly, I will go heavy into it. And if
not, then I will uh wait until puffer
gets to be a little bigger and try
again.
Okay, this actually runs already, which
is cool.
outside. And then there's one other
thing we got to do right
I just wanted to see if it it built bad.
We have to get remote render. Actually,
yeah, I should just start adding
freaking tasks for contributors cuz
there are actually Puffer Lib's getting
big enough that we have people on the
engineering side who would actually be
just like happy to help us fix random
crap. And uh I mean these are things
that actually take me quite a bit of
time to figure out
for future viewers. Yeah, fair enough.
Thank you for the annotations, Bet.
want to make sure this runs and then we
can get it to my local and uh we will be
able to do material science things from
there.
Hello from YouTube. Hey, Weston. Long
time no see. We're doing science today.
Okay. So, this is fine. It runs.
Um, we are set.
my
figure this out.
Somehow the world seems intent on
keeping me from doing RL and just
chilling. Yeah, that's some
man.
We're doing cool material science here.
Well, not super cool yet. I think it'll
be pretty cool in a couple of hours. At
the moment, we're just setting up very
initial bindings.
Hope for variables. It's kind of hard
bet at like
you have to be like legally an adult who
can do things and make your own choices
first.
All right. Forgot about this detected
CUDA version. Uh
a totally different conversation. Mag um
Magnus, you don't have context for this.
on the GPU, is it not? Yeah, magnet.
It's my local desktop is screwy. It's
just it's it's old and I haven't had
time to reinstall everything.
Don't worry about it. We're just I'm
doing this so that we can get a
visualizer built in.
We're not actually going to do most of
the like training and stuff on here.
It'll be for the remote mission.
Yeah. Don't just don't mess that
building yet.
and uh this is not the material science
environment, right? This is just a
template that I've renamed stuff on.
This is the little template environment.
We're going to actually go put the
material science code into the template.
fix remote rendering is on the list of
things.
I don't think it's a puffer thing
necessarily, but I think it's like a
container thing or like an exporting
thing.
I got to figure out how to just like put
a board somewhere like, hey, things we
need people to do.
this
here.
Oh,
GitHub could open it. Yeah, I don't want
to use GitHub issues for this because
it I can't just say like, oh yeah, fix
open issues because other people raise
dumb issues. Like I like I need to have
like Yeah, these are the things that we
need done.
I might do like a Discord channel or
something.
We'll see. I think GitHub technically
has a board for these. I could make like
a board. I hate having boards. But
here we have a goal position. A very
basic environment like But it's basic
environment with atoms. Oh, I guess it's
cool or whatever.
Uh, yeah.
Back three.
Oh, because it's using the just Okay, I
see. Yeah, this is fine. We can do
do this
instead of having a float. We'll just
make this ve 3
whole right
x.
Fix the index for VX for VZ.
What I do
for VZ and third action. What? Oh,
thank you.
Okay, I think I know how we're going to
do this, right? like
The idea is going to be we're going to
make like a very basic 3D steering
environment and then going to make sure
this works and then we're going to swap
in the real uh the atomiculation
package.
This is good.
Added this
sub three.
If distance is less than
one.
Python syntax.
What happens when you code multiple
languages? You screw stuff up. Uh reset
boards terms.
We got to do compute observations and
reset, right?
We'll just do like void computeations
and
doesn't have to be super complicated.
Okay. So just basic basic delta uh obs.
Okay.
The reset
lo everything
nothing
turn
otherwise velocity
distance
this
We do have to do a basic 3D renderer,
but it should be quite easy.
Just going to go grab our uh our drone
renderer real quick and hack it a little
bit.
I think it's in here.
Not
render like this, right? Make
Okay. And that's M script and
Okay. There's a lot of annoying crap in
here.
Uh we'll do it one at a time.
I probably need like a good chunk of
this but not a ton, right? Like I just
do this. Put this thing
in here.
and
window.
You also need a camera, don't you?
Hang on. I That was a little bit over
ambitious, right?
Got to do this.
do this. Yeah.
Sight.
Just do like this. Right.
Why did that indent so much? Oh jeez.
Okay.
Tabs.
And I think we just take this crap as
is, right?
Do like this.
Cool.
Happy with this.
All right. So, this is fine.
And now
I just need to go get the 3D args from
here.
See?
Yeah. So, it's a lot of stuff here.
Honestly, we should just copy the drone
thing entirely and just delete stuff.
It'll be easier to just hack this than
it will be to just make a new one.
Haven't done this. Like, it's been a
good couple of weeks since I looked at
this.
Okay. And now we have to do the particle
which is literally just to draw a
sphere.
It's kind of funny how similar this is
going to wind up being to the uh the
drone environment, right?
Like you can steer drones in space or
you atoms in space. The RL doesn't care
what you do.
Drones are just atoms.
Wait, why are you indenting manually? Uh
because my
uh my editor screwed up, Tiger,
and I don't want to take like a bunch of
time on stream to fix it. So, I'm just
like typing quickly. Dead.
This is not the normal stream setup.
This is like the jank stream setup. All
right.
This is me in California with like a
super old desktop that should probably
just be overheating randomly.
Bet is our our resident advertiser.
So I do appreciate. Yes, bet. Do if
you're new around here, do star the
repository. It helps me out
tremendously. All this work is free and
open source. We have dozens of people
that are now in the open source
community who came in with no RL
experience or helping us to push the
research forward. This is like a space
where with all the stuff we've done uh
this was a very inaccessible area of
research before but now it is very very
accessible and the progress is very
rapid. It's quite exciting.
You also move while in insert mode. Do
I? I don't know.
This is the thing we needed, right?
basic. Super super basic.
So, the plan here, right, the plan here
is probably should have just started
with a drone environment, honestly.
Like, I'm realizing it's basically the
exact same thing.
It's like steering in 3D space. It's
basically just drones. That funny
material science is just drones. Um,
but yeah, I should have started with
that. But anyways, we're going to get
ourselves a basic
minimal environment setup here for
steering around atoms.
Then I'm going to include the the lamp
stuff
and we're going to actually hook it into
the real dynamics.
The goal at least
three noted in here. Is it like ray
math?
Math.h. It's not math. What?
Oh, they have their own vector. very
low.
What I do? What I do?
All right.
Okay. Well, that was something for a
second.
I have come to say I cheer for you my
friend Arin here. Hey Arin, we're doing
material science today.
uh let's see
I do Oh yeah observations
let it be here.
Welcome.
Okay, perfect. So,
Adam
in a box.
Say hello to our atom.
What are you trying to do now? Well, I
have uh a test script for lamps, the
common material science simulation
package that works for like moving an
atom around. Uh, I'm I have puffer liib,
which is really good at reinforcement
learning. And now I'm putting together a
test environment in which I'm going to
include lamps, and I'm going to use
reinforcement learning to steer atoms
around into different configurations and
then test uh what properties these
materials have. And I'm going to
hopefully get this to be useful in
actual material science research.
What can I provide with you? Uh, your
background was in something related to
this, wasn't it?
Trying to remember what was your
background in
it was like something hard science,
right?
chemistry.
Very cool.
So, I mean, yes, related atoms are
atoms.
How does the main method in the C file
work? Building custom. I put all render
controls in C render method
because doing that in the C would not
work. We'll render controls
building custom. So um the C file is not
used when you run from Python. Okay. So
you only include the header file uh when
you are running from Python. The C file
is just meant to be a test file. So you
can run your environment in without
having to compile from Python. Uh so
anything that you only want to be in
that test and not available from Python
goes there. So for instance, if you want
to be able to like control the agent
with the keyboard, usually you want to
just do that in the C test because the
neural net's going to control the agent
otherwise. Um but you know, sometimes
you might want camera controls in theh
file so that at least you can like play
around with the camera when you're
running from Python.
I don't know if that answers your
question.
specifies double
argument has type in?
Ah, dummy.
I see the error. We're good.
Easy. Gotcha.
Hey, look at that. We have an atom moves
around.
Yay.
Thank you. I thought I think it's a very
nice Adam.
Okay. So, here's your goal. Here's your
atom.
I saw some a colleague of mine say,
"Hey, look, this is mostly your fault if
you forgot to site the paper."
But like honestly, if your reviewer
doesn't know what Adam is, that's like
such just a colossal screw up. Um,
that's like such just a massive colossal
screw- up and having that person review
that that kind of trumps everything else
in my mind.
Yes.
And uh, sure, we just see if we can
train
Okay. So, um material scientist link me
the threebody
problem.
Some thermality
liquid
body potential Error.
What a error. side ending up. See?
Yeah, we don't need
this is not giving us back any logs for
some reason.
This uh shouldn't this work?
This should work.
Why is it that this is not showing up?
What the hell?
Um
score log in right
correct to me.
I messed it up.
But I screw up with this. I get this
quite often as well.
Sort of silly.
Well, hang on. This doesn't work.
This doesn't do anything.
required keyword arg size. Well, that's
not true, right? Oh, I know what's going
on.
Never mind. No, I don't.
What?
fired cubid eyes.
take you three minutes. You know, you're
probably right. I should just do that.
Hey, Larry.
and just run the other thing. Right.
See,
There you go.
Okay. So required argument is size.
No, there is no size. That's what's
weird.
You don't need that param.
bubble free.
I'll find it. Don't worry.
Why is it that you never get the uh
There.
Okay. So, now I see the prince on the
goal there.
was getting the goal but wasn't
contributing to score which is weird.
Know what it is? My own thing.
Hang on.
Okay, we are successfully steering the
atom,
it appears
for the most part.
See
here the atom. Yes.
Okay. So now what we have to do is we
have to get the lamps dynamics into this
thing. Uh, let me at least commit Yes.
Okay.
So,
basic
up crap right?
any limit on observation actions basis
for environment. What do you mean any
limit?
You can do discrete, multidiscrete and
continuous boxes.
Typically, you'd like to have either
lowdimensional continuous
singular discrete with like not a crazy
dimension to it or like a
multid-discreet with not too many
components each of which is not a crazy
dimension.
Oh yeah, struct. So technically we do
support structured spaces uh with our
emulated our emulated API but for third
party environments and stuff we do. Our
native environments we advise against it
because like is just really really fast
and we try to avoid doing anything to
make it not fast.
We do technically have actually to be
fair we have the best structured spaces
support of anyone but we don't use our
like we don't use it because even though
we have the best structured space
support it's still way better to just
not do that and have the speed
We do not need to reset our position.
Uh but we do need
Okay.
And this is no longer needed.
something like this. probably need to
fix up some stuff, but yeah, whatever,
right?
Hopefully I have time to fix minor
example of puffer lives as a hole in
Windows.
If you want to get that working, go
ahead. Um, I think our vectorization is
probably going to totally mess up on
Windows. You might literally have to use
serial
unless you use WSL, in which case it
should work.
distance? Oh, I'm silly. Yeah, I got rid
of distance.
Uh, let me go get that back
silly. Okay.
Then I have to do the lamps
link thing, don't I?
Very good.
Okay. So, we have to actually get it to
move. But we have a basic thing. It's
running through lamps.
We have a puffer end.
This is very close. This is very close
to being what we need.
All right, I will uh missing an M. Yes,
exactly. Very silly. All right, folks.
Give me like a couple minutes. I got to
walk around and uh you know, clear my
mind. Take a quick take two. uh grab a
bagel whatever and we will actually see
if we can get the RL to steer the atoms
using the dynamics of this package.
Trivial example for now but as soon as
we put in like two or more atoms it
becomes non-trivial. So, be right back.
This has just been the short
intermission.
I've only been live for um what few
hours not even like three hours.
I'm tired though. It's been a long week.
Probably put in like
close to 50 hours in the last 3 days.
At least if you include all the travel
time.
Yeah, I just did a little meet and
greet. I think it's kind of funny when
people like reply to me, oh, can we meet
up? Haha, you won't see this. I like,
yeah, sure.
All right. So,
motivation is hard to come by with
programming. Not really.
Programming is just at least I find it's
something that does not work when you're
just tired and burnt.
So instead, I don't force myself to. I
kind of like work until I'm like just
dropping productivity. Go do other stuff
for a bit. Right.
Tomorrow I will be
going for a good run
and chilling for most of the day.
Wouldn't even say I'm super hyper
motivate. Well, I guess I kind of am.
They're definitely people who are like
way more fixated on stuff than I am,
though.
Try not to say stupid founder
You know, one of the things that's been
really funny in the last few days
is I talked to um I talked to people in
SF working on various companies, right?
And FS SF is such a bubble. It's
basically like LLMs are the only AI that
exists and the only type of valid
company is a GPT rapper.
And then it's like, hey, you know,
there's this whole other branch of AI
that is uh going to solve problems you
can't possibly hope to touch with
anything you're doing, right? And it's
just like, what? Holy hell, this is
cool.
Late to the stream. How are you
implementing RL and material science?
Um, we have this hooked up to lamps and
the goal is to literally steer atoms
into place in order to produce uh a
specific highle property that we want.
So, it's basically like what if instead
of steering drones, we steer atoms.
If this works, I'm going to post that
for all the people that give me
about doing stuff with drones. It's
like, yeah, the RL doesn't care if it's
steering drones or steering atoms.
kind of the cool thing with RL. It's
like the same same algorithm, same
everything.
All right. So,
why is this not
not steering is the question, right?
Oh, I know why.
Run 10
time step 05.
So, it's actually got to be
Oh, yeah. Look at this. We are literally
we're steering the atom
running through lamps.
Problem is that this needs to not print
stuff.
Good.
Is it good?
always assumed RL would the bigger of
the MLS just for a box of self-driving
planes, boats. Yeah. So, the thing is it
should be
but uh
there was
it's a field in which there is an in
like
just inexlicable amount of incompetence.
Like go look at what we do in puffer and
then go look at SP3 and compare and
you'll understand why it didn't get big,
why it actually still is going to get
big.
You convert calcium acetate into acetone
with it.
Uh that would be
I don't know if this does that. If this
does chemical reactions,
I don't know. I'll have to ask my
material scientist friend if this is
like accurate enough to actually
simulate reactions and such.
I I mainly just use Grock. I use LLMs in
the way you see me using them here,
which is like new package, spotty
documentation, how do I use it? I'm not
really using it to code stuff.
really using it as docks more than
thing.
happened.
Undefined symbol lamps finalized.
I guess I haven't run through this,
right?
Yeah. Hang on. I have to I have to link
the library.
It's not that hard. I just need this and
I need to go to setup.py.
Um,
have to use Yax FF or similar. Okay, so
it does support it but with plugins I
guess.
the excluders
and then actual cards. That makes sense.
I didn't realize there was an includ.
Oh, of course there is. Yeah, that makes
total sense. Being dumb.
Oh, it's not going to like me opening
4,000 lamps, right?
Um,
thought it was supposed to be like
decently fast.
Okay. So, I think we need to change
basic baselines here, right?
Okay. Uh that actually gives us 13,000
steps per second.
20% M time
16 of these
eight
four
Oh, because it's
Now this should work, shouldn't it?
Uh on the bright side, it looks like
we've learned the thing.
Okay,
here we have
uh reinforcement learning
steering an atom to a target running
through a real material science
simulation package.
Now, it is an absolutely trivial
example.
Um, but this is uh this is the basis for
pretty much everything here.
I'm actually kind of surprised this
learns everything in a quarter of a
million steps.
All right.
So,
few things to do from here.
right.
Next stuff to do.
To do
Let's make this multi-agent.
Uh, let's get some more molecules in
here.
Let's see what happens.
Use
that. You forgot to call a function.
You did like step.info instead of step
open close.info.
Are you planning to introduce SIMD?
I believe that can double the SPS at
least double.
So there are a couple environments where
yes, we need to do more low-level
optimization.
Um, if you do SIMD to breakout for
instance, you're not going to do any
improvement because the ENV is already
like 50 million steps per second. So,
you're never going to ever be able to
saturate the GPU anyways. So, literally
all you're doing is going to make the
code more complicated to add SIMD for
literally like for no benefit. Now, for
stuff like GPU drive where it's actually
a decent chunk of the time is simulating
the end, I guess not GPU drive anymore
since we ported it, just buffer drive.
Uh yes, you know, SIMD would help and we
should actually bother to do that.
This one here that you're looking at,
there's kind of no point to doing SIMD
um because all the expensive calls are
going to be into lamps which is already
doing that, right?
The expensive thing is going to be the
force calculation more than anything.
It's force and whatever the hell other
things it does. I don't know
thingies.
what are you doing exactly please? So
this is uh material science plus
reinforcement.
I developed pufferlib. Puffer liib is
the fastest reinforcement learning
library out there and also has some nice
algorithmic improvements to it. We have
very very good reinforcement learning.
Uh lamps is a well-known material
science package for doing atomic
simulations.
And I am currently building an
environment using lamps uh for steering
atoms around using reinforcement
learning in order to produce uh material
properties that you want. The goal here
is to advance material science research
by allowing the Sims to be interactively
optimized via reinforcement learning.
Thanks for the demo. Catch you next
week. Thank you. Walking robot probably
not happening soon. reaching robot or
drones more likely.
Humanoid physics is kind of a pain.
We can do a lot of other good stuff
though.
I don't know. Maybe we could do
reasonable humanoid stuff if I just like
throw away all the heavy packages and
just go down to like warp or whatever
or physics.
I bet in this case it's only really
useful for the slow environments, right?
So, this distance thing is a little
sketchy.
I think what we're going to do is
let's do like ve 3,
something like this maybe
like stick this for loop.
like this.
Okay. And then do
going to flip the condition.
Okay. And now we do
reset at om
x
something like this, right? Let's become
I I
no sim but when I look at M's the data
can align perfectly and there's enough
loops that can benefit But I agree with
the breakout. What M's are you looking
at shadow? So it would this would only
apply to the M's for which there is some
substantial portion of the time that is
actually spent on the end. Right? So I
think that most of our training at the
moment can get somewhere between two and
five million steps per second per GPU.
So if the ENV is faster than that,
right, there's not really any real
benefit. And I like technically yes, it
does help a bit below that because you
don't have to use so many cores and
such. Um I think that really the the
ones that we care about that a lot would
be like
probably the driving end is the main one
right now.
But like a lot of the overhead in the
driving end, it's not even from
computing the N. It's from the data
transfer from the observations being too
big.
I'd love to have some basic SIMD
examples though. Like I've never done
that, frankly. I know what SIMD is
obviously, but I've never done it. I've
just never had to do that level of
optimization for these.
Uh, chess probably as well, but bet
you're kind of trolling on speed at the
moment is my guess anyways. It should be
able to be quite a bit faster as is.
I'll look at it. Where's the material
science?
This is material. Like, do you see this?
All right. This is lamps. Lamps a
material science sim. We're working on
steering atoms with reinforcement
learning.
Steering atoms to become useful
materials.
is bad.
Well, that's because uh
I guess he went to communist school.
Material goods are generally useful and
nice to have. They're not the entire
point of life.
Dogmas are generally
they're good. I think
we need this.
All right. like this.
Something like
Where can I find your Twitch and
YouTube? I'm Neuralmmo on YouTube and uh
my Twitch is the same as XJ Suarez 5331.
I'm streaming. I should be live on all
three unless something is broken.
articles are on X at pods are on YouTube
which is best for latency.
Thanks for letting that.
What time is it? It's only like three
something and I'm exhausted.
Long week. We got to get a at least a
couple good more hours of dev out of me
for this, right?
Like to at least have some basic like
two atom system or whatever or few atom
system where the atoms fly around and do
something.
moving.
When we moving, huh?
They moving
Okay,
this is now a reasonable velocity,
right?
Why you not move? Huh?
Not move.
Yeah, it's randomly sampled. Bet. It
should be vibrating though.
It is moving. Is it? No, it's jumping
around. That's resetting.
Not moving.
We're good, man. I know what it is.
100% habit.
100% works.
There we go.
No, I I was using this end of pause.
Um, this thing doesn't exist.
Okay,
let's make sure it still trains.
What is the quickest thing to train? Um,
Pong should take 3 to 10 seconds
depending on your hardware.
It'll get faster. Bet. This is like an
unbatched
molecular sim.
10 seconds then. Yeah,
long should be decent enough.
Okay. Uh, yeah. This doesn't freaking
train though anymore, so that's a
problem.
How'd this happen?
it just ready to run somewhere in the
Docker container.
Yeah, it's on the puffer AI docs. I
don't think I have this command set up
locally, but puffer train puffer pong.
Yeah. Uh well actually I do main not
device CPU.
Okay so this is like the worst possible.
Okay so this is a whole minute on pong
because this is like 20x slower than it
should be. But if you do that you'll
train it.
Check the docs on puffer.ai. If you get
stuck, ask Bet, who is right here, or
ask in the Discord.
There is a Docker. There's a UV setup as
well. You can pick whichever you want. I
use the Docker for everything when I
can.
Just easier.
Uh, hang on. This is different. I'm
dumb.
Yeah, when you get the Docker running,
everything should just kind of work.
Docker good.
All right, so here you go. This is our
material science sim now with um loops
for agents or whatever.
And if I run papri val in a second here,
you should see it.
Have to get the second atom in.
Here's the two atoms. Only one of them
moves.
Fix that.
Puffer get repo was same as puffer
directory and container. Oh yeah, you
got to get pull from the container,
Larry. It's a pre-built image. So if you
want the latest puffer, you just get
pull,
not building the container from scratch
for you, right? It's way faster to the
image to download.
Uh it's not in like there's going to be
stuff missing, but it's the version of
the container that like the puffer lid
version there is 30 when we shipped it,
right?
Doesn't have all like the latest
force changes.
I do reserve the right to break from
source as well. So
But you're trying to sort out here with
these atoms. Not much yet. We're just
trying to steer them around initially,
but like the diff, it's not that much of
a change, right? Once we have the basics
working, you throw a bunch of atoms in,
you evaluate some property on them, you
use that as the rear ward, and then they
steer themselves around into a a
configuration. The idea.
Yeah. So this works, right?
Okay. Good.
I did a lot of atomic physics.
You know, we the most useful thing in
Pupper at the moment is that having more
people who have experience in other
fields, especially in like hard science
and uh simulationheavy areas of
industry.
Get a couple of those people learning uh
just a little bit of RL, enough RL to be
dangerous.
the uh power all sorts of scientific
innovation with this stuff, right? We
literally have magic sci-fi tech for
superhuman optimization on crazy
quantities of data for like fiddly
unintuitive processes.
So, you should be able to kind of
rewrite a whole bunch of reality with
that.
It's probably the most crackpot way I
could have phrased it, but it's true.
Oops,
that works.
Okay. So, are they both steering or is
only one of them steering?
funny post.
I agree.
Okay, let's see what this does for us.
Hopefully something reasonable.
pretty noisy.
Again, this is a very small scale thing.
Oh, the end of it is actually fast now.
Yeah, it's not bad.
Of course, once we start actually
simulating forces, it's going to have to
do work.
there. It's still 4% like this.
Okay. So, Num M's can go to
better.
The issue
Let me look.
Well, the policy is not good, so it's
not just a logging issue. Hi, Spencer.
Uh, plus+ and reset.
I don't see it in here, do I?
there.
Well, this doesn't help. Yes, you're
right.
What's this? What's wrong with this,
though?
patient.
This is fine.
Yeah, I don't know what I messed up
here. It works with one atom, right?
I have like a hardcoded zero somewhere
that I'm not seeing.
See one.
Thought I got them all.
The question is what happens when they
have force m uh force interaction.
Probably going to want like eight or
like four.
4x32 instead.
That's still fast.
has some fun uh
un view numbers on it.
Holy
We still have quite a few people on X.
Chat's always less active there, so I
never know how many there are.
Uh, okay. This doesn't seem to work
super well, right?
Funny that that messes it up though,
isn't it?
Weird how that makes a big difference,
huh?
Wonder if there is actually some weird
thread safety shenanigans going on.
There's no reason this should happen.
Oh, you know what it is. No, I know what
it is. Hang on.
I just didn't handle this correctly.
This will be so much better.
getting tired and I just want to like
get this basic thing this him done
today.
I think if we have this with the force
interaction be a good thing to have
done.
Oh yeah, there you go. Instantaneous
learning.
We go.
Here is your policy.
Very
This
probably just this line, isn't it?
I have an interesting question. In my
simulation, there's a spawn related bug
that appears
at the time the bug because comes from
low-level engine can't access this
bug
and I end the episode if it appears. How
would you annotate it? Turn truncation
or termination.
Uh so literally puffer lib does not
distinguish between those two things.
You're good for meeting Monday 9:00 a.m.
PST.
Uh, I am. You should DM me what meeting
this is cuz I forget what the heck this
is.
One of the funniest things to me is how
everybody sends me their resumes. Like
they don't send me their resume asking
for a job. They like they send me their
resumes asking to contribute to open
source. I don't need your resume. I need
your code.
Like you just show up and start writing
code. That's all you do. Pretty simple,
right?
People like always expect some hierarchy
I see no chain. Is it parallel or
something?
Okay. Yeah, that's good. Uh yeah, send
me the invite and I'll be good.
Yeah, I literally never bothered
implementing that shadow.
Like I could never bothered.
Oh yeah, Eduardo's question. So in this
sim here, use this as an example.
This is the number of cores I'm using to
run on each core.
This is the number of environments I'm
running on that each core. And then this
is the number of atoms I'm running per
each of those environments.
So the total number of agents is equal
to this number times this number times
this number
is having a seizure. Lovely. Catch
tomorrow.
Sunday is my day off, but I will catch
you Monday,
right? This is what I was doing.
So, I mean, technically, we could
literally just do this and be done if uh
if this works. can do a little bit more.
Might take a few minutes break to like
go get a Tylenol and walk around a bit.
You'll see. Come back for another hour
or so before dinner.
They're probably like too far apart,
right?
Rock is supposed to be able to do all
physics problems.
What is the um tail lamps coefficients
are?
Actually, you know what I should do? I
should just go grab um yeah, I'm going
to go take a few minutes. I'm going to
grab my Tylenol. I'm going to do a
couple things before I like because it's
just going to get worse. Um let me take
my break now and I'll be right back and
we'll figure out if we can get the uh
the atoms to interact correctly with
each other today. So, you'll actually
see them like curve when they get near
each other and stuff. I'll be back.
Okay.
You know, there have been zero materials
discovered so far today. Got to discover
some materials.
Shouldn't be that hard, right?
All right. I was looking for I think the
atoms are just not close enough or
something, Okay.
Okay. So it is tempto seconds I suppose.
[Music]
Just ask rock.
See what is it? Angstroms.
Probably angstrom, right? How big is an
Adam and Angstrom? Like
Okay. So, it's they're all about the
same size obvious, right?
No, he didn't give up. He just moved on
to the next thing until I go like
flame him a bunch and he feels bad that
he didn't get it to work.
Uh, I mean it's
I do think it's actually kind of
reasonable to get the Sim derail working
quite quickly. The problem with him is
he's also doing new form factor like the
drone thing will not be that hard
just like get it to fly around.
do the same thing but with like
ridiculously
What's the plan for today? You're
catching the end of this, man. Been
doing uh material science simulation
work all day.
Sure.
I'll jump in the Discord for a little
bit.
Are catching me at the end of uh a very
long week. So, we'll see how coherent I
am. Do my best.
devices.
Yeah, hang on.
say something.
>> One 1212. Roger. Roger.
>> Yeah, that's good.
All right. Well, what papers you got?
>> Um, yeah, I've selected a few. I think
uh there's like uh three of them that
are very interesting. I'm not sure
exactly how much you think you have time
to go through, but yeah, I think three
is probably Yeah. Um yeah,
I'll link them in the discord.
The first one is uh this one.
Um
they've basically the issue they tried
to tackle is that uh you know mutual
information skill discovery is easily
fable
>> um in the general in the discord.
because you're gonna you're gonna throw
me heavy math at the end of the stream
at the end of a long week. Let's see
what this
>> you know if you can if you can't do it
that's completely okay. I'm going to try
with this.
We have
I don't think that this thing fundament
works, but I think it's a good auxiliary
going
What do you mind just elaborating a
little bit on why you think this
wouldn't work?
>> Well, I mean, this has just been
something that's been done for a very
long time and none of the like no reward
RL stuff has really done anything all
that impressive.
And let me
Is this entirely humanoids?
>> Uh yeah. So most of the papers are
mostly focusing on robotics. Yeah.
Because I guess this is where the main
uh issues come from.
So the you know the main issues I found
across all the papers that the x-axis is
always in steps. Uh I've never found a
single paper where they where they're
they bring on the time constraint but
>> welcome to academia.
where the uh
>> yes their code is in test. Uh you can
see the main and
>> yeah I mean it's better than the last
one I showed you. Is this based on is
this min or what is it?
>> The main algorithm is in IoT.
I'm not sure exactly what you're looking
for, but the the main algorithm logic is
in IoT and the main uh training logic is
in test, but yeah.
Yeah, you have the LSD,
you have the LSD Python file uh right in
the IoT folder.
>> is Z like skill back.
>> Z is the lightened variable uh of the of
the it's the skill.
Yes, I think yeah, I think that is
uh let me see because in some of those
papers that they don't onehood it but
yeah I think most of the paper is one
hot
>> I mean if I had to simplify it the way I
understood is that is DN but just with a
lipshit constraint to make sure that you
know the skills aren't just easily
distinguishable
without highly different trajectories.
That's the way I see it.
>> That is what you want.
Oh, I only recommend that people who
know that they want to do a
general
probably just link me all the papers.
That will probably be more effective.
>> Yeah, sure. I could then uh I'll I'll
link them to you ranking them from what
I think is interesting. Um,
>> and this card is it good for you?
>> Yeah.
So that's if you're interested in my
text. It's basically like an advanced
version.
>> It's funny how like literally every
single one of these papers has oh the
other methods do nothing and ours does
everything.
>> Yeah. So one of the big issues I found
is that most of them also have hard time
um reproducing the results to the
previous ones.
Um so I agree with you. It's a bit weird
on that.
Were you um interested into map elite
sort of stuff or did you think it it
wasn't going anywhere? Uh so the issue
with maple each is again that you're
training separate policies
>> because I found one that is kind of
doing some sort of map edit stuff but in
two latent space uh representation of
the parameters or something but it it
seems quite interesting
>> works very very well in places but it's
you're training you're training separate
policies so you're splitting your data
horribly.
I see
>> you also have to define like the axes of
variation
the the three. Okay. So I just linked to
you a last one and those are to me the
most interesting ones. Then all the
others basically had big issues when I
looked into it. Um most of the time it
was
just highly specific domain knowledge
input into the extreme uh intrinsic
reward somehow. So I just gave up on the
that one. I'm still a bit suspicious
about whether or not they've put like a
lot of um do knowledge into how they
create the latent space of the state
space cuz they basically
thing
doesn't show
thing only shows coverage on this one m
Okay.
Um, Ron, I linked the papers in Discord,
but I can link them in the chat also if
you're interested.
>> They're in Discord. Discord.gg/puffer.
GL puffer.
what you're looking at when you're going
>> I'm just trying to see I'm just trying
to go through and see if like what like
what results various different are
Okay.
This thing
work.
The thing is it's basically the same
guy. So
>> yeah.
Well, actually kind of funny then, isn't
it? Because
two labs are basic thing.
This says
they say that.
Yes.
SD
>> that should be CSD the way they uh
printed.
Yeah, it's a different one. Um,
CSD is another one and I just linked it
in the Discord right now.
That's it.
Follow up one.
Okay. Isn't this the same thing? Hang
on. This is the same thing as this
the direct followup.
>> Yeah, I think it is basically.
So the difference is they basically the
same algorithm but in latent space in a
different uh in a different metric space
>> isn't this the same they have this and
isn't it just summed over time or is
there bigger difference
this is a sum over time
you.
Yeah, this looks like a sum. Isn't this
just a straight sum over time
difference?
>> I think if you implement one of these
like these, you kind of get both of
these.
>> Oh. Oh, yeah. at uh children. Yeah.
>> Now, I don't know if this is going to be
slow if you do this or not, right? I
think you can maybe make it not slow. I
think you kind of turn this into um
you might be able to turn this into a
sum or something.
I think you can do this as like a
cumulative sum over a segment.
>> Yes. So, I think the big difference with
us is that we won't have full
trajectories for an entire episode,
right? So, if I do this
Yeah. Right. Yeah. Exactly right. But I
think it's going to be good enough, but
we need to have a long enough segment if
you put this too small. Yeah. Right.
>> I agree.
>> Because one of the things you said to me
last time was also that uh uh you need
to do something trajectory wise,
otherwise it's not meaningful enough. Um
And so the only way to
you know I thought about what you said
that we couldn't interfere through the
states and so I think most of those
papers just uh work around this by um
building an intrinsic reward right it's
just
because you can't do that then you have
to force it some somehow
uh and that's what they do most of them
>> what is this doing.
>> Uh, which one is it?
>> Also, this
>> actions on cybernetic.
Yeah. So, those one Okay. Yeah. So those
ones are basically to my understanding
they basically added an exploration term
to the skill discovery uh reward.
[Music]
probably like the best known products.
Am I missing something or is this one
pretty easy? Oh, this an LSD.
Yeah, I think they're uh very very
similar.
>> Just add an encoder somewhere, right?
Add like an extra little encoder and
then you just do this in the train step,
right?
In the train step, you have to do this
extra loss thing. Yeah, pretty much it.
This a reward or is this uh
differentiable? Hang on.
in LSD or you're in Metra, right? Yeah,
Metra.
>> Is this a reward or is this
differentiated through?
I don't want the AI to summarize
wrong.
Yeah, to me it's a reward.
>> You think this is a reward?
>> Let me see if I can find
>> How do they train this component?
minimum. What's this temporal distance?
Hang on.
I mean to me this is a reward the policy
but then the discriminator is uh trying
everything is differentiable. So for
this one is it's it's trained through
grad and descent.
>> Okay. So you have to you just compute
this thing then in the train loop. I
think
>> uh you it in the train loop before you
like
have you have to compute this thing in
the train loop to add to the reward
before you do advantage.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah.
>> Enjoy your studying journey. New follow
currently learning. This is not me
learning deep learning. Um,
this is doing
uh reinforcement learning buffer.
We're looking for things to pull in from
other uh other sub areas that have
gotten a little bit of attention in the
last few years.
We do have resources for people learning
deep uh like just general deep learning
though.
I' I've been doing deep learning since I
was like 16. This is uh I mean this is
like obviously not an area that I spend
a lot of time in this thing. If you are
new,
most of the stuff around here is RL, but
check the X. Same as the uh Twitch
handle,
have guides for general ML and for RL.
To me, the way we would implement those
is very very similar to the way you
would implement.
>> I think so, isn't it? Like they're all
kind of pretty similar.
>> Yes.
>> I would just branch three hack it and
like the thing is I think if I'm not
wrong here and I'm exhausted like I've
been like it's been a long week but I'm
pretty damn sure that if you just
>> if you just set t to one you get LSD.
Don't you
>> uh definitely do not use tensorflow
spirit. Do not use tensorflow. Use
PyTorch. If you must use Jacks, use
Jacks. But do not under any
circumstances deal with TensorFlow
Dax is kind of a freaking mess though. I
think generally PyTorch is the way to go
if you don't have a huge amount of
support on specifically Jacks. Have a
reason to do Jacks.
Yeah, it has a lot of backup by Google
if you're at Google. If you're not at
Google, then everything is a mess and uh
it's on you to figure it out.
>> Yes. So you basically think that those
are interesting
>> and if they're the same thing or because
I don't know if they is defined
differently
if five is defined the same. They
release code with this one.
>> Let me see.
>> Yes, they did.
>> Yeah, they did.
Yeah. Sorry, I don't have all the
details in hand. I basically went
through so many of them. But uh
>> oh, they actually have a blog post as
well.
The big issue I have with all all of
those ones is that they train first in
the unsupervised way and then they go
down for downstream tasks. Uh I don't
think that's something that is efficient
enough.
>> Just mix the objectives.
>> Yeah. So you would basically mix the
rewards, right? So you would probably
have like the And I I guess my intuition
says that you would start to have most
weight to the interesting rewards first
and then slowly have it decay and give
more and more strength to the
environment reward.
>> Hang on, Spirit. You don't need to read
500 pages of anything like at all to
learn deep learning.
Harris is kind of awful. Um here, look,
the advice I give to new people in ML,
there's some advice on how to read
papers because you do have to read
papers. Um where's the ML section? Just
have you done two have you done CS231N?
just like go go take CS231 and it's
online. All the course materials I
believe are online. Watch the lectures
by by Car Path 8. Um be a dramatically
better use of your time. Like it's it's
maybe like a month's worth of full-time
work. Um and that will teach you at
least like as much as the average um
average AI engineer in Silicon Valley.
You can't just read a book to learn.
Like you need to actually do stuff
interactively.
Here, I'll link you the article cuz like
my articles link you to everything else.
Like these link you to all the
resources. There's also general
programming stuff in here, but there's a
section at the bottom for ML.
And then there's an RL specific one.
The RL is my main my main area.
ML. Yeah. So I mean the deal like my
deal here, right? I'm a researcher. I
finished my PhD at MIT like a little
over a year ago. Uh I'm working on a
very high performance reinforcement
learning open source tools and we have a
whole dev community around that. It's on
discord g/puffer.
Um, I don't typically do a lot of
educational material, but because people
asked me for it a bunch, I wrote a
couple of guides and people have told me
they're very helpful. So, they kind of
link you to all of the best resources by
everyone else. Kind of aggregates
everything in one place for you. Uh, I
have more stuff for RL specific than ML,
but like general ML, it's pretty much
just a course, a few projects, and like
getting decent at general programming.
that and learning how to read papers
which I cover.
Okay. Um
I need to like actually go through this
paper as a thing to see if they did
anything like obviously insane. Is there
anything that you could direct me to
that you were like not sure about?
>> Let me look at my notes. Um
>> yeah, no worries. I'm I'm a little tur
today. I'm a bit tired. It's been a long
week. I've been doing um reinforcement
learning for material science all day on
stream as well.
>> Oh, how did that go?
>> Oh, yeah. You didn't see that. So, we
got uh we got puffer bound to lamps,
which this very commonly used material
science sim. I got a couple DMs from
material scientists like asking to chat
about this as well, which is awesome.
Um, we basically have a thing where we
can steer atoms around, have them be
simulated with uh, lamps and we have to
like get the forces and stuff to be
actually realistic. So, that's next. And
what we're going to do is do stuff like
specify
uh, like the heat dissipation or such
that we want
and have the have the atoms learn to
steer themselves into a configuration
that uh, achieves that behavior.
And obviously if they do that right you
can look at the material you can look at
the final configuration say okay I need
to make that material
sounds
you were able to do that in just under a
day right
>> well I'm not saying it's any good yet
but I do have it bound to the main sim
science material science is generally a
broad area encompassing material
discovery
highly computational. A lot of
computational methods, experimental
methods for discovering new materials
and engineering materials with specific
properties.
>> Uh you ask me about suspicious stuff on
the balancing.
This is a long paper. This is too much
content for me to be able like go line
by line and tell you like and find
everything at the end of a long week.
But if there's a specific area that you
said, I I didn't know if this was legit
or not the way they did this. I can
definitely like look at that and spot
check it for you.
I skipped programming. No.
Can I do martial arts and skip learning
how to hit people?
I mean in LSD I didn't find anything
archively suspicious to be honest.
>> Okay. And did anything in um
>> but if if you tell me so I think the
idea of uh of this right was uh for uh
us to
out
>> the stream actually uh restart or
something. Uh, hang on. It's dropping.
Second, folks.
I think we're done dropping frames.
Be good.
Are you there? uh boxing.
>> Um
yeah, see you hear me?
>> I'm not dropping frames any seconds.
>> Okay. Yeah. Um so if you agree with me,
I think the idea was that, you know, we
go through a couple of papers. If you
think they're interesting enough, then I
just uh uh I put some time in and try to
implement them with buffer.
>> I don't like I don't look like going by
creds. Sergey's group though does
generally do good stuff and it looks to
me like they have a continuous line of
work. Believe they did Diane like
several years ago as well and it like
they're like getting better every gen.
And the the nice thing is if you
implement one you've kind of implemented
both. I don't think they're particularly
complicated.
I would like it if they had if all these
papers had more baselines against each
other because like I don't see any
baselines on this thing.
um SD.
>> Yeah, nobody else has like independent
implementations of this thing. Um or
this one either CSD.
They they all have baselines on Diane
and dad's
and
that's all I saw
unless I missed some
more questions.
What do you do for undergrad and
graduate? Undergrad at Stanford computer
science graduate with MIT. Yes,
department is huge. My specialty is
multi-agent read learning. What
else do you haven't read it spirit? I
like I've never read any tech like full
textbooks. I've read like sections of
textbooks. I've never read any full
textbooks on AI or or ML or anything. Um
it my opinion it's like it's good as a
reference. It's not as a good way to
it's not a good way to learn though in
general.
You need to learn you need to learn
through experience.
Need to actually do projects and see how
stuff works. especially
in AI. AI is like a highly empirical
field.
Um,
did I miss something or does nobody have
baselines on these? Like are there no
independent baselines on these oxen?
No, I think uh the most common ground is
Tan and then they're just missing some
of them.
>> I see not CSD.
>> Yeah, CSD is a different one.
>> Yeah. So, like they all have baselines.
The only thing that's a little sketch is
like some of them do they both have bad
l? This one is the only one that has bad
base.
Yeah. So, this one has a bad base. Like
this one says that this is not that well
not even actually no it has it better
than Diane. So still fine. This says
that it's like a good chunk better than
Diane or else. And then this one says
hang on.
It went by train cur. Well,
>> yeah. The the biggest sketchy thing I
found across all of them is that they uh
really focus on state exploration, which
is great, but there's very little uh
done about actual rewards and downstream
tasks.
>> Why didn't you join an AI lab?
Uh because everybody's doing the same
bloody thing, Ronaldo. Everybody's just
doing LLMs. like they put 99% of the
focus into one area. They're like
completely missing out all this other
stuff in RL. Like they're just obvious
hard problems across all industries that
are not going to be solved with LLMs.
Just nobody's doing it. Oh, I am doing
it.
Actually, this is kind of a closer
comparison, right?
This would be worth looking at because
these these claim to have very similar
results, right?
Results. This one the results kind of
suck on, don't they?
This one has
Well, I don't actually know if this one
sucks. At the very least they don't show
>> yeah they don't behaviors they only show
>> that one I was a bit a bit suspicious
because the result they show on uh so
they benchmark against and uh it's uh
the results seemed a bit lower than on
the original so
>> let's say if we go through these these
two seem to show similar results right
like look this is the same task
this
this All right.
This
humanoid
does actually claim better results I
think. I don't know. Pixels.
Okay. So, we actually do have to look at
the difference between these two because
I think they're claiming quite similar
results.
I think generally the other the Metro
one has better benchmarks and
everything.
>> Mhm.
>> There's the D.
Whose group is this?
Peter's appeal. Wait, is this the same?
Wait, these are the same authors.
>> Aid is not in the in his all of them,
but the Shiong Park is in every one of
them.
>> So if the first author is the same, then
this is
2023.
This is a followup.
Why did they not their own thing?
>> Wait, what the hell? Why did they not
benchmark their own paper
like from before?
>> Good point.
That's sketchy as hell.
Maybe there was a review or something.
>> Thanks, Ronaldo.
I mean, maybe Sham I don't know who
Shamp Park is. Maybe he was the
supervisor and didn't really got
involved in the
>> That's not how that works.
>> That's not how that works. The first
author is the this like main student on
it's the supervisor is the last author.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Peter Aiel is a profit Berkeley. Spill
be a prophet Berkeley. Very close labs
right next to
what is now.
Um
yeah. So the first like authors are
always the
Okay. So then you're
Yes. Then you're very right. Okay. So
the the first um the first version of
Metra was in 2023 and the first version
of CSD was in the same year. So
um
actually Metro is like a okay a couple
of months older than CST. So it still
raises the question.
>> Yeah. If you look at the first versions,
uh the last versions of Metro is 2024,
but the first one was do they do
different
at the same time
>> topic
and not compare to himself.
I
>> mean they site in Metra they site CSD.
So
>> okay
>> that's weird right?
Trying to see how this is actually
computed.
I mean to me it's very similar, right?
>> Yeah. Hang on. Cuz it's a it's a state
based as well.
>> Well, you're looking at
>> X and Y. Now you're looking at DSD,
right?
>> Oh, wait.
>> Yeah, sorry. The stream is
>> still here. It's still
>> They don't show the computation. This
>> Sorry, I lost the strangers. I can't
really see.
>> It's okay. Hang on.
Yeah, you have it on page five
or the code. Sorry.
Which paper is this? We're looking
through a bunch of SE parks. Um like
exploration slash diver
Okay. So this like basically it looks
like like all this code he's been
building up on this ford.
Um,
Okay. So, actually these are both
follow-ups to um LSD. He did two
separate follow-ups to pay.
I think we just need to understand the
uh the difference because he has two
very similar papers that are both
follow-ups to him earlier paper
>> between CSC and Metro.
>> Yes.
I think it's likely you're going to end
up wanting to all of these
and they're going to be very similar.
Yeah, if you're okay with that, I think
it's probably also going to be better
for you in terms of uh time. Uh like I
might start implementing the LST and
then move on, try implementing.
>> There's one thing I noticed.
>> Uhhuh. You're going to want to just
says right here theation of LSD in here
is
much better.
So if you're going to like the this is
the thing to start with I'd use this
one. This is like He basically tweaked
his original and then added some new
stuff, right? Added like this these
changes and now it's the new algorithm.
So the it's the combination of these
improvements
plus the algorithmic uh changes. I would
look here
>> like right here.
Um, yeah, your stream dropped again.
>> Dropping.
>> Not sure if it I don't think it's me
because I still hear you on Discord, but
>> I haven't dropped any frames
>> before.
Okay. Well, I think that this is most
likely
most likely the play. Now,
pretty much all of these have some sort
of state difference of encoders, right?
Like encoder state difference thing. Um,
what you're going to want to do is
there's a Diane branch. Okay. It's kind
of old, but you can see it.
>> Yeah, I looked at it. uh couple of weeks
ago.
>> It has like the
paparella in here. Oh,
>> it was the old one. So, it's still demo.
I think you still had the demo fight,
right?
>> Yeah. Where's up?
Okay. So, this is
Yeah, I have all like the Diane stuff in
here. If you look,
I think the main thing is
Yeah. So the main thing with Diane is
like the sampling from the like the
sampling of the indices
I think you have to
I think you have to do it in this train
function though. I think you have to
recomputee it back the advantage.
But yeah, this is this is what I would
start with. I'd start with probably like
the of them. You're going to want an
environment, by the way, that's just
like good for this type of research. I
would just hack on.
>> Yeah, I' either just like Yeah, do that
and hack on that.
>> You might even just have like might even
just like make an empty map one. Modify
that. Make an empty map and see they can
go in different directions or whatever.
>> How's the RLM? RLM. I'm not I'm not a
I'm not doing a master. Um,
All right.
Yeah, I think that it's like fairly
likely that there will be something
here. um the author of Dian actually.
>> Oh that was Eisen Batch I think for D.
>> Oh okay who also is thousand.
>> Oh let's see
I think if one of those papers like
actually replicates then they probably
all will. You know what I mean? Same
author.
>> Yep.
>> Like built off the same code base. I
think that what I would do is I would
spend a little time just getting the
basics of like these delta state metrics
in and make sure that's right like a
super simple environment or just like
policy has to go to a place right or
like
even do the no reward version if you
want like you should be able to train
that in 30 seconds or less.
So you should actually have a very very
quick iteration cycle on this
and uh if you've got time over the next
few weeks do that then I can help you on
the actual experimentation side once you
stuff just like basically port up my old
Dian stuff and hack on that. That'll
give you a basis for this
but don't use dian use at least like
oh ms material science. Yeah yeah yeah
>> we'll do 28.
All right, cool. Um, yeah, thanks for
dropping by. This will be very useful if
you get this
>> uh if you get this to work. I think this
will unlock quite a bit of stuff.
>> Okay. Yeah, that's quite exciting. I
might be a bit slow for the next 3 weeks
because I'm going to be on a holiday,
but uh yeah.
>> Okay. Well, thank you.
>> I I'll I'll get back to you as soon as I
have something going on. Sure.
>> If this works, this will be very very
good on the side because like this will
also help us with multi- aent selfplay.
something I have to start on quite soon.
>> Okay. Well, that's quite exciting then.
Thank you very much for your help. That
was very helpful.
>> And uh good luck.
>> Thanks.
>> On.
Okay. So,
oh, we have quite a few people watching
at the moment. Hi everyone. So, the uh
the deal with this stream is I'm a
researcher in reinforcement learning. I
run Puffer AI, private lab. Uh, all our
stuff's open source. We do ultra high
performance reinforcement learning. Have
a whole bunch of demos on our website.
On load,
this one.
We have a whole bunch of demos on the
website.
My internet just totally screwed.
Shouldn't take that long to
Something's definitely Oh, yeah. There
we go. Okay. Yeah, we do high
performance reinforcement learning. So
if you're interested in that
the Discord lots of dev going on
definitely just that
great. All right. Anyways, we were doing
material science stuff before. Going to
take one last look at this stuff before
I call it and go for dinner.
So, I was having trouble getting this
thing to run with
Fix this real quick.
How's the atomic control worked?
This is still very early, Andrew. Like,
I got some basic stuff to run, but it's
not really enforcing many of the real
dynamics yet.
What are the prerequisites for RL?
Uh, I have a guide on that.
These two guides collectively will
uh will tell you everything you need to
know and link you to all the resouring
and and ML guide. There's the
specialized RL guide.
So the result here should be that all
the atoms
steer towards this target.
Oh, actually there it goes. It's kind of
working.
I am both a condensed matter physicist
and learning R&D. Why the stream caught
my attention? The paper about diversity.
So that's totally different. So that's
like core reinforcement learning
research.
thing I'm doing here. Uh, this is so
I've gotten lamps, right? And I've
hooked it up to puffer lib as a puffer
end. So, I can run reinforcement
learning where the RL is steering all
the atoms around. The idea is that we're
going to be able to get them to steer
themselves into a configuration that
matches some highle property that
evaluate.
Demis is done. Lex Freedman podcast
again.
Yeah, I really don't listen to too many
podcasts. I probably should watch that
one though.
Interesting that this learns a bit and
then it kind of gets stuck.
All right, this is actually learning. I
mean, we'll see what the result of this
looks like. This is a very bad reward
signal as well. This is kind of just our
initial test. So, this should actually
get better from here.
See if it's stable or not.
densed matter learning art. Yeah. MG if
you're around like Discord. GG/puffers
where we do all our research and more
than anything at the moment we are
interested in how we get reinforcement
learning uh to advance other fields of
science particularly those that rely
heavily on simulation
article you mentioned learning C why is
CM libraries
okay well the fact that you bring up a
sklearn is enough evidence on its own
learn some low-level dev um learning
low-level dev of like is going to just
save you a lot of pain and suffering
because like most what happens a lot of
the time is researchers themselves
by like not being able to make anything
fast because they just won't step out of
Python
and they literally have no idea about
anything whatsoever about performance
because they literally don't understand
anything about how the hardware works.
So doing low-level code both allows you
to write stuff that is performant, but
even if you don't do it super often, it
allows you to have some idea of how fast
your code should actually be to stop
writing code that is literally less than
1% efficient.
All the RL researchers are just yeah we
just eye torch everything for uh years
and like they have no idea about system
stuff and like RL the entire field of RL
was running 10,000 times too slow for a
decade
that's what Puffer fixed
okay
this is kind of decent
Wait, why are they in a line like this?
Bizaro, isn't it?
How are they in a line? It's clearly
like a messed up observation or
something. No,
doesn't look like it.
Y go Z.
like if you just want to be a scientist,
then go ahead. But you'll never be a
good engineer if you just do everything
in Python.
You'll just always write horrendous slow
things.
is very very easy. And the fact that
people think that like low-level stuff
is hard, it's just it's just myopia.
Low level is very very easy. In fact, I
honestly I find it easier doing a lot of
stuff now in C than I do in Python.
like I can't I could not write something
like this in Python because it would be
slow
in some sense. You just write very
simple code and it is fast. Obviously,
you can optimize even more than that.
Get fancy like you'll basically
everything is instantly 100 times
faster.
The neural nets aren't in C by the way.
Not the I mean the neural nets like our
neural net training is not in C.
like here you literally could not
implement one of the like you couldn't
implement some of our environments in
Python like if you go implement neural
MMO 3 in Python you can spend years
optimizing it and you'll just always be
like orders of magnitude slower
I know because I did exactly this.
Literally, the code is just effortlessly
faster
for many things. And if you just refuse
to learn things because you think you
can do everything high level and never
touch anything closer like closer to the
actual hardware, you're simply wrong.
Doesn't mean you can't be a great
scientist, but you'll never be a great
engineer.
So weird that they like they're gathered
on a line like that is odd.
I really just don't enjoy
is just easy for me. There are probably
times when there are things that you
want, but like for everything I do, it's
C is just really simple. Don't have to
deal with insane things.
Um,
is a very simple language and if you
keep it simple in C, you can just get a
lot done very quickly.
Couldn't get DQN to work.
DQN isn't really supposed to work. Bad
algorithm on its own.
kind of does a few
like C like the thing is spirit C is
very easy
like it's not even like a huge thing
like oh I got to go learn this and that
it's like you understand the basics of
memory allocation what is a heap what is
a stack that is about it like Just write
very simple code.
Things are fast. Just it's an effort.
It's an exercise in simplicity within
anything.
0 one two.
This should be fine. For some reason,
it's like biasing in the line.
incredibly odd to me.
What about the security dimension of C?
You're writing research code.
Nobody cares about the security of your
paper implementation
or your like like your training test
suite,
not deployed applications.
Like if anything, you'll train a model
in a sim and then you'll deploy the
model, not the sim.
the list of problems you'd like to try
RL with.
Um, well, I think like initial
applications and areas that having more
people with experience would beful,
right? Uh, we want to do stuff in
material discovery.
We're doing some stuff in robotics.
We've got drone things uh in progress
help. Uh, we want to do a six degree of
freedom arm. I haven't done it yet. I
think we could do a standalone six
degree of freedom arm very well. Um
there's stuff in biosciences that I want
to get to eventually, but doing
simulation for bio is generally much
harder is my understanding.
There's probably stuff in other areas I
haven't thought of. Right.
But it's pretty much any like any
disciplines of science or engineering
where simulation is very core.
Food is interesting. Yes. And the cool
thing about CUDA, right, is if just if
write low-level C, like it takes you a
day to be able to implement basic CUDA
stuff. You literally just copy paste
your C into CUDA and it runs.
This CUDA is just C that runs on the
GPU, splits parallelism across
dimensions that you specify. All it is.
CUDA is not hard.
It's a pain to debug something. Not
hard.
This is just like a bad
Fine.
Well, it will take you months to learn C
when you're new to programming, right?
That's expected.
You don't like when But like I could go
pick up any new programming language, at
least any reasonable programming
language in like a few days now.
It's expected that it takes you a while
when you're new to programming in
general
or new to low level.
Either way,
these things do not come naturally or
easily to me
spent a lot a lot of time programming. I
spent a lot a lot of time on AI
research.
This is reasonable lat now, right? Like
this is at least a good enough baseline
here
for steering atoms.
making the big tech is an
it just it takes it takes time and work
these are not simpative.
I think this is good for now. This is a
decent spot to I actually I'll push this
so you guys can play with this if you're
interested.
All the stuff is open source
immediately. Might have to mess with
some stuff to compile a little bit. Let
me at least fix that up a little bit.
Oh, is this going to fail to compile
though?
I'll just I'll put this like this so
that it doesn't include this. You guys,
if you want to play with this, you can
just move the knot or whatever.
Okay, so there you go. There is material
science plus RL uh on the GitHub.
Hopefully this not broken anything.
See if we have anybody complaining at me
on the Discord.
like I broke anything.
Okay, cool.
Um, I got to go grab dinner.
Uh, I'm sat, uh, Sunday is my day off,
but I will be back on Monday with more
dev most likely. A ton of things to work
on. I got a new article to write. I've
got a poster to prepare for RLC or two.
So, if you're interested in all this
work generally,
all of my stuff is at puffer.ai. It's
all open source. You'd like to help me
out for free, start the GitHub really
helps.
And if you want to get involved with
development, go.gg/puffer.
Had dozens of brand new RL people get
into space through Puffer. We have a lot
of material to help you along the way.
not that hard if you have a basic uh
engineering background. Ideally, a
little bit of AI background.
Other than that, you can follow me on X
for more RL content where all the
articles are. Be back likely Monday.
Thanks folks.